The Joe Rogan Experience I think
exercise is the single most important
longevity drug we have Bar None like if
you if you were if you said like I want
to go deep down the rabbit hole of
living longer what do I need to do
it's it's like a super well crafted
exercise program that is geared towards
strength muscle mass and
cardiorespiratory Fitness so it's all
the above it's not just one right so I
mean the hazard ratios for each of these
are pretty interesting we've this has
become like each year I try to bring one
new focus into our practice and the past
12 months the focus has been entirely
around taking exercise to a new level in
terms of our understanding of how to
fine tune it and the data are
unbelievable right so if you everybody
knows that if you smoke or have diabetes
your risk of death goes up a lot but
your risk of death
from having high cardiorespiratory
Fitness goes down by much more than your
risk of death goes up from smoking or
diabetes
so smoking and diabetes will double or
triple your risk of death depending on
the time frame you're looking at
having very high cardiorespiratory
Fitness so having a VO2 max that is
Elite we would Define that as the top
2.5 percent of the population compared
to below average is a five-fold
reduction in all-cause mortality death
from any kind whoa I mean there we don't
have drugs that have a 5x reduction in
mortality that's incredible and that's
just Elite cardiovascular health right
and then when you layer in strength and
muscle mass we actually now have pretty
good data as to the fact that strength
is more important than muscle mass we
just use muscle mass is a good proxy for
strength but if you just focus on
strength that's the metric that matters
it's about a three-fold reduction in
all-cause mortality when you compare
high strength to low strength and the
tests are you know we're talking it's
not like how much you can Squat and
deadlift it's like grip strength dead
hang how long can you do like an air
squat you know like what's your quad
strength how quickly can you do five
reps up and down from a chair I mean
it's relatively simple stuff but when
you stratify people by those metrics and
you compare the highest to the lowest
performers there's just no comparison is
there a point of diminishing returns
though where you just get really really
strong but it's not helping you any more
than being fairly strong on the strength
data we don't see it because the data
have only been parsed out as high to low
on the cardiorespiratory there is a
point of diminishing return so remember
I said Elite is the top 2.5 percent and
then you so it's it's it's it's
um we break them into five categories
but they're not equal in bucket size you
get most of the benefit Honestly by
going from not fit at all to average fit
that gives you three of the 5x now that
said you know I I hold myself and my
patients to a way higher standard which
is we have a chart that shows all the
data by age by gender and by VO2 max and
I would say if you know if you're a 52
year old male I'm asking you to have the
VO2 max of an elite 42 year old male so
I want you to be a decade younger Elite
and then we do the same thing with
strength metrics and when you prescribe
that like say if you take a a 52 year
old male that doesn't have a history of
cardiovascular activity you know maybe
they you know lightly work out the gym
or something like that what what
particular exercises do you think are
the best to achieve that result so we
start with a base of zone two so this
zone two is that lactate thing I was
talking about so your zone two is
defined as the highest level of aerobic
output that you can generate while
keeping lactate below two millimole so I
think a bike is the easiest way to do
this because the stationary or
stationary just because it's you can
keep it steady state you know when
you're on the road it's all you're all
over the place but um so if you're on
like a you know a stationary bike and
um so you and also wattage is such an
easy metric for people to understand so
how many watts are you putting out right
so
um the first thing we would do is say
you probably need to be doing at least
three hours a week of that zone two
which is building an aerobic base so
four 45 minute sessions at Zone 2
constantly driving it up and honestly
one session of VO2 max training per week
and the best protocol for that is the
4x4 protocol so that's four minutes at
the highest output you can sustain so
here you could do it on an air bike or
something right so you could do what's
the highest wattage you can hold for
four minutes and then four minute
recovery and do five of those sets once
a week
so when you're doing that do you think
that the best is like an air dine that
works the arms and the legs or do you
think just a regular bike that just
works the legs like what is for zone two
I mean it really just matters that
you're consistent but I think most
people find you can do a higher output
when you're on an air bike in terms of
absolute wattage because you are
leveraging upper and lower body it
really doesn't matter that much I mean
you can do this on a treadmill you can
do this on a stair climber you can do
this on any kind of cardiovascular
activity but you need 45 minutes four
times a week that would that seems to be
the minimum effective dose on zone two
now if someone's super deconditioned it
can probably be three 30-minute sessions
to start and they'll see benefit
um
interesting and then as far as a
strength program like do you recommend
specific exercises is it like squat
deadlift well it depends on this is
where it gets very dependent on the
person so we have a test that we put our
patients through that's
um 10 exercises
um and they're all basically normalized
to your body weight and gender so like a
dead hang so how long can you hang from
a bar dead so for me should you be able
to hold well we hold males to the
standard of two minutes and a long time
yeah and females to a minute and a half
at the age of 40. so then it gets
discounted by decade watch the entire
episode for free only on Spotify